we are ghosts we aren't afraid of death
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in May 2000 nineteen Ubisoft announced
Ghost Recon breakpoint which will be the
sequel to the 2017 Tom Clancy's Ghost
Recon wildlands previously I put
together a video on a roundup of the
full wildlands story I'll pop that into
the description if you wanted to catch
up on what the ghosts have been up to up
until now in this video I just wanted to
start out with a super quick
introduction to the breakpoint story
based on the trailers and promotional
information that we've seen so far and
depending on the interest we can then
start digging down into the nitty-gritty
of the Ghost Recon universe the gamers
sit in the year 2023 four years after
the events of Operation Kingslayer and
wildlands the story takes place on
aurora an island in the south pacific
owned by billionaire entrepreneur Jace
Kell it's now home to scale technology
Jace scales a tech genius some of his
inventions can be seen in wildlands
scale has the brains power and money to
do incredible things like turning an
entire island to the headquarters of
scale tech but he also has a sense of
hope hope that he can use his technology
to help the world scale technology is a
blue chip company producing drones for
commercial applications but it has also
found success as a military contractor
developing cutting-edge equipment for
the United States government scale
purchased Aurora with the vision of
turning into a hub for the design
research development and production of
artificial intelligence and drone
technology the island is made up of
marine histories wetlands forests
snow-capped mountains and active
volcanoes
as thus Celtic gets more and more
advanced and becomes autonomous the risk
opposes to humanity increases and if it
were to say fall into the wrong hands it
could spell disaster
basically mounting evidence that its
products are falling into the hands of
corrupt regimes scale technology starts
coming under increased public scrutiny
when the company is implicated into an
assassination
the United States government decides
it's time to investigate further only
for a rower to cut itself off from the
outside world after crash-landing on to
the island of Aurora nomads the leader
of the Ghost Recon fire team has to
regroup with his team while overcoming a
series of obstacles put in place by a
mysterious group that is hunting them
down they find out that a former ghost
and close colleague coldy Walker has
gone rogue and that a private military
contractor named Sentinel has occupied
the island under walkers command and
Walker himself is leading a team of
soldiers calling themselves the Wolves
armed with cutting-edge weapons and
equipment the Wolves have commandeered
scale technologies drone production as
part of a self-appointed mission to
safeguard the future of warfare Walker
has made no man in his team a target and
he's willing to do whatever it takes to
keep his hold in her own part of the
mission is to find out what happened to
Walker what turned him from a loyal
soldier to the leader of a rogue
military unit and what happened to Jay
scale
[Music]
the ghosts have their work cut out for
them they're coming up against
potentially the most difficult foe yet
ex-special ops agents that have
reprogrammed advanced AI drones to serve
as their own personal killing machines
the ghost will be pushed to the limit
without the Intel backup or the
resources that they've come to rely on
in previous iterations of the series
there it is
short and sweet this video is just an
introduction of break point as a gauge
of interest on the channel so tell me
moving forward is this the sort of game
you'd like to see me cover more in depth
with the odd dad joke thrown on of
course let me know in the comments the
Ghost Recon universe has built up a huge
amount of lore and it's almost 20 years
of franchise history and I'm definitely
looking forward to this game due to be
released in October
2019 anyway thanks for watching and I'll
catch you in the next one
Cheers
they have an army we fight with our
brothers and sisters
[Music]
they are hungry but we are to rage
[Music]
we are ghosts